seit wochen tobt ein heftiger sandsturm
auf dem mars wurde heftigste seit dem
menschen den mars beobachten und er hört
einfach nicht auf anfang juni
entwickelte er sich wuchs enorm an und
umspannt mittlerweile den kompletten
planeten mit heftigen konsequenzen
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum
science fiction
mitte juni gab es die ersten
konsequenzen die nasa musste mitteilen
dass der kontakt zu ihrem rover
opportunity abgebrochen ist ein
absolutes drama der mars rover curiosity
dagegen hat wohl noch energie und zwar
aufgrund seiner radionuklid batterie
forschungsteams nutzen jetzt alle
möglichkeiten um das heftige
wetterphänomen genauer zu untersuchen ja
und wie man sich so einen staubsturm auf
dem mars vorstellen kann und ob
opportunity wiederbeleben kann das sind
die fragen ja quasi jedes jahr gibt es
staubstürme auf dem mars teilweise sind
sie groß wie ganze kontinente auf der
erde
doch der aktuelle sturm ist besonders
denn mittlerweile umkreis der den ganzen
planeten solche maß staubstürme können
plötzlich auftauchen und monatelang
andauern bei dem aktuellen sturm scheint
es sich um mehrere kleine aktive stürme
zu handeln die sich zusammengeschlossen
haben wahrscheinlich ausgelöst durch
einen einzelnen lokalen sturm der ende
mai beobachtet werden konnte ende juni
deklarierte die nasa das wetterphänomen
als planeten umfassendes staub ereignis
schon zu diesem zeitpunkt waren 41
millionen quadratkilometer betroffen
mehr als russland und nordamerika
zusammen und das hat folgen für die nasa
und ihre rover auf dem mars der feine
staub bedeckt ihre paneele und stört die
elektronik anders als im film der
marsianer aber ist der sturm war lange
nicht so wuchtig wie dort dargestellt
das liegt an der dünnen atmosphäre doch
es gibt eben trotzdem negative folgen
denn der sturm blockierter sonnenlicht
und der rover opportunity bekommt jetzt
keine sonne mehr ab die seine
solarzellen für energiegewinnung nutzen
können opportunity hat jedenfalls seit
mitte juni keinen kontakt mehr zur nasa
er hat sich wohl weitestgehend
abgeschaltet dies passiert wenn die
akkuladung soweit feld das sich der
rover selbstständig in einen ruhemodus
versetzen dann ist nur noch seine uhr
aktiviert die ihnen dann nach einiger
zeit auch wieder wecken könnte bis dahin
sollte opportunity wieder etwa
sonnenlicht gesehen haben und seine
akkus mit energie aufgeladen haben dazu
ein projektmanager der nasa john callas
wir machen uns sorgen aber wir hoffen
dass
der sturm aufhört und der rover mit uns
kommunizieren wird man könne durchaus
noch optimistisch sein denn seine
batterien hätten insgesamt noch 85 ihrer
ursprünglichen kapazität behalten und
das trotz der bereits mehr als 5000 lade
und entladezyklen es handelt sich
schließlich um die besten batterien im
sonnensystem glück im unglück haben auch
weil der sturm jetzt im sommer auftreten
die nachttemperaturen sind dann
vergleichsweise mild nacht sind es um
die minus 33 grad celsius dem rover
könnte ohne den betrieb seiner batterie
dennoch im schlimmsten fall dasselbe
schicksal drohen wie dem rover spirit
der 2010 wohl auf dem mars eingefroren
ist opportunity selbst ist schon seit
ende januar 2004 auf dem roten planeten
unterwegs und hat die ziele seiner
entwickler damit längst übertroffen
ursprünglich war geplant dass er 90 tage
lang den planeten erkunden soll
mittlerweile hat er in den 14 jahren
schon rund 45 kilometer zurückgelegt der
mars rover curiosity dagegen verfügt
wohl trotz des sturms weiter über
energie das liegt an seiner radionuklid
batterie ich hatte erwähnt die ihn
unabhängig von sonnenlicht macht bei all
den negativnachrichten sie die nasa in
dem gigantischen sandsturm aber auch
eine chance forschungsteams wollen
endlich mehr über dieses wetterphänomen
auf dem roten planeten erfahren warum zb
treten sie in einigen jahren auch in
anderen aber nicht warum sind sie
manchmal so gigantisch und manchmal so
klein wann und warum weitet sich ein
regionaler sturm zu einem globalen
phänomen aus antworten auf diese fragen
könnten dabei helfen mehr über das klima
des mars aber auch über seine
vergangenheit und vor allem über seine
zukunft zu erfahren denn für zukünftige
mars mission deren pläne ja immer
konkreter werden wäre es sehr wichtig zu
wissen in welchen dimensionen mit
solchen stürmen zu rechnen ist genau
dazu ist jetzt eine absolut optimale
gelegenheit seit dem letzten großen
sturm im jahr 2007 hatten planeten
forscher und forscherinnen förmlich
darauf gewartet denn langfristig gesehen
plant man die entwicklung von modellen
die als werkzeug dienen könnten um
solche staubstürme vorherzusagen also
vergleichbar mit den vorhersagen von
hurricanes
und so weiter auf der erde doch dafür
ist erst einmal eine ansammlung großer
datenmengen mengen eine wichtige
voraussetzung drei auge sondern könnten
das übernehmen zum einen der mars
reconnaissance orbiter lro der ähnliche
wetterdaten und bilder wie irdischem
etwa satelliten liefern kann zudem auch
die sonde maven die die obere atmosphäre
während des sturms beobachtet und zudem
auch die sonde mars odyssey die über
eine infrarot kamera verfügt und somit
die dichte und beschaffenheit des
staubes analysieren erst in diesen tagen
hat die nasa jedenfalls klargemacht dass
der staubsturm weitere missionen in der
zukunft nicht verhindern wird man habe
in den letzten beiden wochen beobachten
können dass der sturm seinen höhepunkt
erreicht habe und sich die massive
staubmenge in der atmosphäre langsam
beruhigen wird ende november soll ja der
insight länder auf der marsoberfläche
abgesetzt werden man gehe fest davon aus
dass der aktuelle stimmung dann
abgeflaut seid doch selbst dann gehe man
von einer abstaubt nebel aus der dann
weiter in der marsatmosphäre hängt der
macher nicht nur die landung selbst zu
einer herausforderung sondern könnte
dann ebenfalls den einsatz der
technischen geräte behindern wenn er
keine videos dazu wir werden natürlich
über die folgen berichten und über die
landung und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei
whatsapp darum geht die kaputte abo
boxer auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
von allen videos und zwar noch bevor es
die leute hier auf youtube erfahren und
zwar täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die bürger
vergessen und hier geht es weiter damit
du dafür auch draufklicken
sensationsfund auf dem mars der ist
wirklich sensationell bis dann bleib
dran